[Music]
i'm dave ramsey your host
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author number one
best-selling author
is my co-host today also my daughter
will be answering your questions about
your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight
two five five two two five
anna is with us in jackson mississippi
to start off this hour hi anna how are
you
i'm good how are y'all better than we
deserve what's up
um we have got about 6 700 left in the
hsa that we
don't contribute to anymore um because
my husband is at a different employer
now
and we wanted to know what your opinion
was of
taking that money and putting it towards
a car loan that we have or keeping that
in there for future medical expenses
well you're going to pay substantial
penalties like cashing out a retirement
if you do that
if you take it out right and so i'm not
going to i'm not going to give the
government 30 30
of my money right well we just wanted to
be sure that that was the right thing to
do since we don't contribute to it
anymore we just
wanted to see what you had to say yeah i
would use it for medical as it comes up
and get it cleaned out that way
in the meantime there's a company that
we endorse and i personally use
called health equity and you can put
mutual funds inside your esa and if you
want it to work a little harder
you could set it in a mutual fund and uh
in in my case
i have never touched my hsa i've just
added to it every single year
and it's become a whole separate
investment strategy
and so forth and that's what you guys do
too right it is and i feel like that is
one area though when we talk about
investing
that doesn't always come up i feel like
people just naturally gravitate towards
the 401k the roth
you know all of that which is the first
thing you should do absolutely yeah
but it is a different vehicle which i
don't think a lot of people realize i
mean even talking some of my friends
will
they'll mention the hsa and i'm like
well yeah we use that more for investing
like wait what if that's for health
yeah but you don't have to use it for
health if you don't use it
it just it becomes a a tax deferred
growth and you can take it out at 65
with no penalties yep yep
and so you'll pay taxes on it but no
penalties and of course if you use it
for medical at any point
uh there's no taxes at all on it so it's
completely tax-free money
for medical so yeah i would leave it in
there for medical tax-free money is a
lot better than
tax penalized and taxed and penalized so
it's going to reduce it too much so
it's tempting like it is when you're
sitting on an old retirement account to
just
speed your debt snowball up but the cost
is just too high i mean you're going to
pay 2 000
to get four that just that's crazy
you know that's just mathematically
crazy all right will's with us will's in
richmond
virginia hi will how are you i'm good
how are you
better than we deserve what's up awesome
um so i'm a pastor in the area and we i
live in a parsonage and when my wife and
i got married actually
three years ago today congratulations
she moved in with me
thank you and she owned a townhouse that
she bought
not too terribly far and because i live
we live in the parsonage
then we pay rent we decided to try to
rent out her town house through a rental
company so that
it was more hands-off we're not in it to
make a ton of money but to still
build that equity as much as we can
while we're
still renting and i've just heard too
many horror stories of pastors who
aren't building that equity as they're
in ministry and they retire and they
have nothing
so we're trying to pay that off earlier
we're in baby steps four five and six
and we're just wondering since this is
our only home should this be a baby step
six or after we max out our roth iras
since it is an investment property we're
planning to keep it for a while can we
even
add more to it and baby step four as an
investment property
uh well i mean i would stick it in baby
step six i would just see it as your
primary residence even though you guys
are renting obviously something else
right now
uh because of your situation but i mean
i would still just see it as your home
because it is there yeah just go ahead
and knock it here's the thing
neither one of these answers are in the
dumb column
okay you're going to pay it off and
you're going to invest and so
none of these answers were just go crazy
okay so you know you're asking the right
kinds of questions you're on you're
sniffing around the right thing
but a simple way of looking at the
parsonage is part of your compensation
you're living there free quote unquote
but
it's part of your comp plan really and
um
then as you said a lot of pastors that
have parsonages get to retirement and
don't have any money for a house
because they've lived in a partnership
their whole career and that's a really
dangerous
scary future if you don't plan around it
so
you're very wise to do that and i
completely agree with rachel yeah let's
go ahead and just stick it in baby step
six
treat it like it's your personal
residence because it kind of is your
future
personal residence or the sale of it
would be used for
your future personal residence someday
so yeah let's just stick it over there
and pay it off as quickly as we can
for people that are in that position
would you ever recommend
them just selling it if it doesn't hurt
and then keeping that money for a down
payment late you know like you can
that's not a bad thing if it starts to
be a hassle certainly a problem like
you've mentioned you know possible
problems with tenants that kind of thing
yeah
if you get into all that there's nothing
wrong with that but what a pastor
you pastors out there that have a
parsonage what you have to do
is you have to make some kind of a plan
to have a place to live at retirement
right and that could be paying yourself
a house payment into a mutual fund
and you could call that your baby step
six and i'm just gonna
pay you the equivalent of what would be
a house payment into a mutual fund
since i don't have a house payment now
sure and uh
and let that mutual fund be the house
purchase fund at retirement idea
so it's almost a sinking fund idea we're
getting ready but and it's way
out there you know it could be a 30-year
distant future thing
but still it's um you can really get
yourself in a pinch
uh and um
pastors often do this they they don't
they're very generous people generally
they're very kind
very obviously they're pastoral you know
they're compassionate
but they don't stop and take care of
their own
looking out there that way and and god's
gonna take care of me in the future
yeah but god's god's telling you that in
the house of the wise
are stores of choice food and oil that's
in the bible and so
wise to store up some choice food and
oil so when you need it
and that this is the investment plan to
do that so if you're in a parsonage make
some kind of an arrangement something
like paying yourself a house payment
into a mutual fund or
being in his situation will situation
where you've got a property that you're
paying off you're going to use that
product say all that property
or move into that property even but more
than likely 30 years from now that
townhouse is not going to be where they
want to live
more than likely they'll sell that use
the money from that to buy their
terminals sure but that's a that's a
good plan and
uh pastors have some unusual things uh
you know housing allowance
as an example um if you're if you're not
in a parsonage there's some unusual
things in the taxes they can opt out of
social security
for their pastoral income uh they've got
some unusual things in the tax law that
they're allowed to do
uh that if you use them properly and you
think long term with them
then it really can add to your
your wealth building plan yeah if you're
strategic about it that we want you
men and women serving in the in the
pastorate to have
so there you go this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why
they offer benefits like tuition
assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
she's the author of the new york times
bestseller number one
bestseller know yourself know your money
discover why
you handle money the way you do and what
to do about it
and also available now is the know
yourself money assessment
and it's available for couples if you
are married and you take the know
yourself
money assessment you're going to find
out a whole lot of things about yourself
and your spouse and you'll be able to
look at each other and go oh
that's what's wrong with you
that's what that's what your mother did
when i took the disc profile
almost 40 years ago i come home and i go
this thing completely mailed it it read
my mail and she's reading it she said
yeah i'm like isn't that amazing she
said yeah that's what's wrong with you
that's wrong
that is me that's not what's wrong with
me oh my gosh
oh well yeah well we love we love
assessments
i mean from disc or enneagram anything
that kind of just like
you understand more about yourself and
why you do the things you do so
obviously that's one of the reasons i
wrote the book know yourself know your
money to kind of dig into the money side
of that
and then this assessment just pairs hand
in hand i mean it really is to
to be able to walk through and answer
questions and something comes out in
this pdf and you're like what
yes that's it that's it that's it that's
it that's so great
yeah the uh know yourself money
assessment for couples
it's very inexpensive jump online at
ramsey solutions check it out you're
going to enjoy it
socrates said the unexamined life is not
worth living
and uh so there's something i don't know
because we're in the transformation
around here and into hope uh
you know whether it's ken coleman or
whether it's us on the money side or
george or
whoever we're always talking about what
makes people tick and what makes us
what makes ourselves stick john dolone
is like the ultimate right he's going to
unpack
more crap about you than you even wanted
to know right and so
uh but you know what makes you tick what
caused you to do that what made why did
you react that why did i react that what
what's the
and even when we're taking calls with
you guys here on the air you know it's
it's an in this whole human animal thing
is fun
it's just fun know yourself money
assessment for couples check it out at
ramseysolutions.com jeremiah
is with us he is in jacksonville north
carolina hi jeremiah how are you
i'm doing well how about yourself dave
better than i deserve what's up
all right so to kind of tell you where
i'm at right now i'm 22
and currently serving in the military
thank you
oh thank you um i have about a year left
on my contract
and i'm planning on attending school
next year once i get out using my gi
bill
i have about a thousand dollars saved up
in an emergency fund as well as three to
six months of expenses
and have no outstanding debt um
i got about 50 000 put into a mutual
fund and
with little expenses after i have
budgeted for the month
currently i'm putting that money that's
left over uh
towards that mutual fund yeah but my
question is my question for you is uh
do i continue to keep putting money into
that mutual fund or is there a better
alternative that i could be money
putting my money towards like right now
i mean for right now jeremiah i mean the
mutual fund obviously is a it's a great
place
to be putting everything we will say
when you put money in the market
to know that there's going to be
probably a five-year gap there just to
know because the markets will go up and
down so doing short-term savings for
instance this is why we
don't advise putting your emergency fund
in a mutual fund because you're like hey
i need to get it to it quickly
and who knows what the market's going to
do but if you don't have a purchase that
you have
in the next five years if there's
something to make a house
or college or something that's coming up
i mean the mutual fund is still is still
a great spot
to be putting that money because it's
it's sitting there and growing and it's
a great insurance policy
to say okay you've got the military and
you've got the gi benefit for tuition
you've also got a stipend coming right
oh yes
they'll give you was 200 bucks a month
or something
uh roughly yeah and uh so you've got
that stipend coming and if you don't
manage to live off the stipend
and you don't the gi bill doesn't cover
everything then you don't accidentally
wander into a student loan debt and so
that's your backstop
to make sure no student loan debt when
you graduate what are you going to study
i just something in business or finance
i haven't really
picked a specific area yet but that's
the direction that i'm looking forward
to going
to like towards my career well you're
you're wise beyond your years you really
have your act together i mean you've got
50
000 bucks you've served in the military
you're 22
you've got a fully funded emergency fund
and no doubt i take it right
uh no no debt yeah where'd you learn all
this
um actually it started in high school
but my mom my mom started me pretty
young with dave ramsey
oh okay so you're a financial peace baby
uh yes i actually got to see you in a
louisville
so okay when you were just a kid just a
little kiddo just wet behind the ears
here's something else man
i'm proud of you i know your mom is
that's very impressive
very impressive a lot of people wishes
their 22 year olds sounded like you
and uh it's pretty impressive very well
done yeah you're gonna be in great shape
and just use that 50 000 as a backstop
if you don't touch it which is the
preference right uh and you get out then
rachel's right it will have sat there
and grown for five years or four years
and you'll be able to use it for a great
down payment on your first house
and uh and you're going to be in really
really good shape because that 50 is
probably going to be 75 or 80 by the
time you get there
that's awesome very good stuff michael's
with us michael is in bozeman
montana hey michael how are you
i'm doing well dave good how can we help
well we are retiring and we've
read your books and have been able to
get debt free
and we've paid for our building
for our office and our home and our cars
they're all debt-free
and we're just wondering if we should
lease out
our office building or sell it
because prices are pretty high right now
for
office building and we don't know which
way we should go whether we should lease
it and use the
lease as retirement income or
sell it and put that into our mutual
fund and use that
for retirement it just depends on what
you want as an
investment both ideas are great ideas
i'm a real estate guy so
rachel's husband winston runs all our
real estate and uh he and i for sure
would keep it
but we like it we like real estate i
mean the office we moved out of to move
into the new headquarters here
two years ago we've leased it up and
it's a wonderful asset now producing a
great income
and so if you can do that and you don't
mind dealing with real estate real
estate has a much higher rate of return
overall if it's well managed and good
piece of real estate then mutual funds
will but it's also got a lot higher
hassle factor
yeah that's that's the thing we're we're
concerned about because right now
the uh inflation has well the
the building prices are inflated
much more than we think they should be
and so well
selling them yeah i don't think you're
going to see i don't think you're
going to see you may see the rate of
value increase slow down but i don't
think you're going to see a retreat
unless there's something
some kind of structural problem with the
bozeman montana
particular economy and i'm not aware of
one of those i think that
you know it's a great little town and i
don't see any
i would think you ought to be able to
release that and keep it
okay but but i mean it's it's if i were
but if not if you're not real estate
people okay
if you hate it and you dread it yeah
sell it yeah there's no it's no
it's no fun to own real estate i mean uh
tenants are you know it's a it's a
freaking reality show sometimes
[Laughter]
if we i mean we're going to we're hoping
in part of our retirement to be
out of the country for a couple of years
so we'd have to have a management
company to
run yeah the building and that's part of
our quandary is
that's an additional expense so we don't
know how much we'd be making there
well run some numbers on it uh you know
have a property management firm or a
commercial real estate person in the
area run some numbers okay if you lease
it out on this
what you're looking for is you know
obviously your gross potential rent
which is if it's full
all the time which never happens minus a
vacancy rate
minus your projected expenses it's a
fairly easy budget to pro forma to run
equals what's called noi net operating
income
and you look at that and you say that's
how much money i'm going to make plus
it's going to go up in value plus i get
to shelter that
by depreciating the building and so
there's three places you get a return
those three added together are called
your internal rate of return in real
estate
and my internal rates of return are
north of 15 to 17
on most of our properties get a bunch of
residential single-family houses you're
going to be out of the country managing
i probably would sell them off but
commercials a lot less
drama and a lot more stable stream of
[Music]
income
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and my daughter
is my co-host today in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free
stage ted and laura are with us hey guys
how are you
doing great doing well good good so
where do you guys live
we live in the austin texas area awesome
very cool
welcome to nashville and here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
223 550
550 how long did that take
27 months 27 months
yes sir very cool good good night and uh
what was your range of income during
that time
155 up to 225.
way to go guys wow what do you guys do
for a living
i work in information security for a
large healthcare company
oh that's horrible that's a wonderful
career right now
i'm a cpa you're a cpa awesome man you
guys got two great careers very well
done no wonder you're making so much
money
so what kind of debt was this 224
thousand dollars it's our mortgage paid
off your ass
yes i'm looking at weird people proud of
it
wow look at you guys so
what inspired you to do this well
um we took fpu several years ago in
uh 2014. just to get on the same page
with money we didn't really have any
big debts or anything but after we got
on the same page
we just started working the baby steps
four five and six didn't really think
about the mortgage that
time at all and then we had a huge blow
up in our marriage big crisis
and fortunately god is so faithful and
brought us through that time
and afterwards we sat down and wanted to
refocus our obedience on the lord and
what he wanted for us
and part of that was how can we honor
him with our finances
and so before that time we had a lot of
discontentment
kind of with our with the cost of living
in the area that we live we
we bought our house when we were 24
years old and the cost of living had
continued to increase
and our income hadn't increased to match
that so we had kind of a lot of just
discontentment
leading up to that point with the cost
of living and then uh after god had
brought us through our marriage crisis
we had kind of a a different perspective
different outlook on life
kind of adjusted our our priorities and
we were you know now we had a
perspective of gratitude and
thankfulness
and um let's see we
we wanted to just honor god and be good
stewards of the money that we did have
that god had blessed us with
so we became faithful givers tithing and
supporting
a few missionary families in our church
and our church
yeah we we became more connected in our
community our local church community
and our local community what church do
you go to
we go to hill country bible church in
austin texas yeah
our church just did a debt free scream
for paying off that there
yeah so they did theirs last week we're
doing ours this week i love
it very very cool well that's perfect
yeah so this sounds like a um
a a crisis that caused you to flip a
whole spirit your whole spiritual life
on your head i wanna said to where you
said okay
uh god you're gonna become the lord of
everything
of our marriage our kids our money and
that change your chain
flipped your perspective is what it
sounds like that's right we had
uh we got we totally got off of social
media so we could focus on
getting connected with our local
community
[Laughter]
we had uh we had two more children since
that time to bring the total to five
kids now well why not yeah
so god has blessed us and just uh
with that backdrop we had a vision of
paying off our
mortgage before we turned 40 and that
vision required us
to have faith and trust and rely on god
to do that because at the time we had
that vision it wasn't feasible on paper
for that to happen
based on the amount of extra money that
we had to aggressively pay off our
mortgage at that time
and we're standing here today uh 39
years old
[Applause]
touchdown what's this house worth
eight hundred thousand dollars
the market may be slightly inflated but
you know what i'll take it you know i'm
putting it on paper i'm just saying
now that makes you guys into the
millionaire status as well then that's
incredible so
you gotta have some retirement going i'm
sure yes yeah way to go
what happened in those two years though
because you said on paper you know it
wasn't feasible but
did were there raises that happened was
there like what what
cool things happened in your story in
those 24 months to make it happen so um
i work part-time my part-time suddenly
looked a lot closer to full-time okay so
i really cranked it up
yeah ted got a bonus and really um you
rarely say this but the government
helped us
they started handing out money i heard
about that but not just
that they also started feeding our
children two meals a day
five days a week and let me tell you
when you have that many kids that really
cuts down on the groceries yes yes
absolutely wow very good you guys
so proud of you what a great
transformation i mean paying off the
house is awesome
paying off the house and having all the
life change that you guys have had is
even that's the best
yeah this is what really matters this is
just icing on the cake yeah
just shows the faithfulness of the lord
yeah that's right do you like you guys
as a team
because i'm sure the crisis brought you
guys to rock bottom is what it sounds
like and you kind of have this whole new
viewpoint on marriage right working
together and the messiness of it all did
that
help you do you think working as a team
as a couple yeah
definitely help us helped us build
momentum and be on the same page and
just
continue together yeah every focus on a
goal in obedience together
was was really great yeah it's good
great for every marriage
yes yes absolutely how's it feel
feels like freedom yeah feels amazing no
house payment
no payments at all you don't have any
payments you all know that you have only
payment
yeah i don't have to think about what's
in the account at the end of the month
because there are no bills at the
beginning of the month
i live in an 800 000 house and it's paid
for
go out and dance in the backyard i love
it i'm so proud of y'all
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of thatis
being on the same page being in
obedience to the lord
tithing i mean if you are walking
together with god
with your finances i mean nothing is
impossible
i mean our numbers are pretty extreme
and it's only because
we were walking with the lord he made it
happen yeah you knocked this out
amazingly fast once you decide to lean
into it
wow very cool 39 years old weird people
all right you brought the kiddos with
you bring them up on stage what are
their names and ages
okay here they come we have
kate who's 11.
we have hannah is nine oh she's cute
abigail's seven lindsay is three
and the baby tai here is four months
oh hilarious yeah all right oh sweet
so the little guy makes the scene here
at the end that's
gonna grow up in a house full of sisters
i love it
very cool very cool this is awesome guys
what a great family
you guys are amazing we're so proud of
you we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story
you've changed your family tree in so
many ways in this story
uh the back story must be absolutely
incredible and just uh so proud of y'all
your heroes you took control and uh and
you relinquished control
to the lord and said you know set this
stuff out front
so very very well done also copy the
total money makeover to
give away to someone so you can pay it
forward and help get their
journey started big ty's ready to do his
scream
all right ted and laura kate hannah
abigail lindsey and ty
224 000 paid off in 27 months
house and everything making 155 to 225
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
oh my wow
[Laughter]
so precious oh i know i could feel laura
was like all right let's do this let's
do this
there's ty oh my gosh so fun you guys so
quick before nap time i got that girl
i know that routine i know that routine
it's awesome
so so great i've seen it at my kitchen
table
[Laughter]
it's wonderful oh how fun
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author new york times best-selling
author
of the latest book is called know
yourself know your money
along with the know yourself money
assessment for couples
and on top of that she's my co-host and
and my daughter but on top of that we
have the
speaking of their marriage it made me
think and i ran out of time to get their
debt-free scream into that segment
but they're talking about their marriage
meta went through a metamorphosis a
transformation
and that led them to to flip on
uh a more spiritual noble view of money
yeah you know handling god's money
rather than on our own and um
they had already been doing smart things
but they their reasons behind it became
more
theological than financial uh but we've
got the marriage and money event coming
up
yes money and marriage money and
marriage yep coming on uh
next friday night so next friday yes
okay
a week a little over a week up on me a
little over a week now yes so
um you and john deloney yes so we'll be
doing it together we tag teamed it last
uh this will be our second
that we did and our first one i'm not
gonna lie you guys it's pretty fun
it was pretty fun yeah well it's you and
deloney neither one of you neither one
of you are support on here because it's
a it's a live stream so you're watching
it from your home right and usually with
with that kind of stuff people it's in
and out this was i think the large
the longest viewed viewed of any ramsey
livestream event
i'm not gonna brag i'm not gonna wreck
that was the stats that they gave us
which means
it's really fun and it's really
entertaining
really exciting and it's it's an
important topic though because when you
dive into
money and marriage there's a lot of
messiness there's obviously a lot of
conflict and fighting
but when you can get above it and a
little bit below it too and just to say
okay
here's the pieces of what makes
a marriage whole and healthy and how we
can attack this subject as a team is
just it's it's huge
yeah well they're they're just tied
together all the time
if you're married it's money in marriage
it's just i mean
ever since i've been doing this i
thought i was teaching money and they
kept people kept saying you healed our
marriage and i went i didn't do anything
in your marriage
just confused and then it turns out we
did yeah you know and then people would
come in and say well i changed my
marriage like that couple
and it made us refocus on our money yes
and so it can go it's chicken and egg it
can go either direction
but you gotta have both the chicken and
the egg i mean you gotta have both of
them working together to really have a
high quality marriage and a high quality
wealth building thing very few horrible
marriages bill wealth
uh very few people uh
that are horrible at building wealth uh
and are just
chaotic there that that chaos doesn't
run over your responsibility doesn't run
over into their marriage yep yep
and so it just it the things are tied to
gather
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five janine is in abilene texas
hi janine how are you hey i am so glad
to hear your voice my friend
and rachel gosh you guys are phenomenal
it's amazing to hear your ads and all
the stuff that you offer
i've been watching you and listening to
you for a few years
i'm in a kind of a sad sex situation i
can say yippee i'm dead free
i'm totally debt free but um i'm in a
situation where
i'm farmer janine from abilene but i got
no money
and i'm 61 years old and i'm getting
ready
to sell out i'm dealing with the toxic
situation after my father's death
who was my farm partner
and um you know our tractor got
pulled off apart so
um my heart's not in it here anymore
and um what i make
from this place which looks like around
i don't know four hundred thousand
dollars
i'm gonna put into the next place i go
to and i think for about half of that
maybe just maybe i'll find someone who
has that love in their heart that
needs to move on somewhere else and i
can find some place
that i can still be the farmer still
make those grasses and meadows and
the love that god gave us and um
walk forward from there but i'm kind of
trying to i'm i'm
overwhelmed i mean this is like a
20-some-odd year move
it's part industrial part
just personal and empty now i'm going
through my house i've done a lot of the
sad sad things i've had to do
the one thing i got for my father's life
was a nasty note for my mother
with a broken hammer and a boat tied
around it
and i'm still grateful for that humor
you know um so what is it
we can best help you with today huh well
what i what i want to do
you know when i've i've been watching
recently uh financial peace uh cash flow
planning
like i said i have no doubt everything's
paid for i have an old truck but it
works like a charm
you know i take good care of it and um
everything i have here is paid for so my
thing is
how do i best protect my assets and make
that work for me walking forward because
what i'm going to do is i'm going to try
and find
as much as i love my church here that's
probably the only thing that i'll miss
right now
is that i just want to walk forward and
into a new community i've already kind
of figured out the direction
i want to go it was a really odd move to
say i have to move away from toxic
into something better and i figure about
half of that
is probably what i'm going to need to
make a new start and then that other
house
has to go into the rest of my life you
know let me
let me tell you let me tell you what i'm
hearing okay
yeah um
[Music]
an amazing amount of the roots
of your life are all being pulled up at
once
oh yeah and there and the loss of your
dad
um
the loss of the dream that was you were
going to be on this farm
until yeah the heart of it the loss of
what should have been with family and
isn't
because they aren't and there's just a
whole lot of pain in your voice honey
and and that doesn't make you a bad
person that just means that's what's
happened
yeah and that just means you're human
and so um
yeah i i think what's gonna be really
important is for you to move
slowly in your future moves
uh and to give yourself some time to
heal because you're pulling this up by
the roots
yep and uh then you're going to move it
over here and replant it and we've got
to make sure
it takes hold before we start going
crazy over here so i i want you to make
a bunch of big investment decisions
that are permanent i want you to move
slow and give yourself some room to cry
because if i were in your shoes and you
would you've lost your
your dad the dream of the farm
everything that the farm represented
the connectivity to your church the
connectivity of the community
the toxic family members that shouldn't
have been but are
they're not filling their role properly
and so you're going to have to go over
here
and set some new relationships and as dr
john deloney talks about the way you
overcome trauma
is grief the way you overcome trauma is
community
and you you need a lot of room to grieve
before you start making a bunch of
investment decisions
you're planning with a brain that's
foggy right now
and uh and that doesn't mean you're
inept it doesn't mean you're not
capable it means right now you are
hurting a lot
that's what i'm hearing oh you can i
mean yeah i think everyone listening
right now can hear that in her voice and
the
there's an urgency too janine so i think
that the advice obviously to slow down
and slow down it's gonna be really wise
because we do find
people that are in these big transition
periods that come from tragedy
can make really poor financial decisions
again not because
you're unintelligent but because you're
literally just making these on the go
with
with a foggy brain so slowing down
um and then finding okay what is my
dream you said farming is something you
love so to have a goal
maybe in 24 months in 12 months
just slowly i'm okay if you don't buy a
farm and you don't do any investing for
a year and a half and you just move to
the new community
and just spend some time weeping spend
some time building new friendships and
new community at your new church
spend some time getting to know the dirt
in the area before you buy dirt
spend some time slow down a little bit
give your toes give yourself a little
wiggle room here to where then when
you're telling the story it doesn't go
in circles
and that means you it means you know the
fog is lifted but we all tell stories in
circles when we're freaked
and and we all have been there honey
they all know how you feel
so be praying for you that puts us hour
of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author new york times best-selling
author
is my co-host today as we talk about
your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jennifer is in washington
dc to start off this hour
hi jennifer how are you i'm doing great
dave thank you so much for taking my
call today
our pleasure how can we help first of
all oh yeah so i want to thank you guys
number one for everything you do is
awesome i just love your show
and i've been listening for a couple
years kind of off and on i wish i knew
about you 20 years ago
but hey at least i do now and i'm i'm
doing better so right now
um so i'm 47 my husband's 54
we're both working full time we owe
right now about 377 000 on our house
we have no other debt so we have
everything else is paid
we do are putting 15 percent uh for
retirement
good we do have a good amount in our 529
for our two kids we have a 19 year old
and a six-year-old
wonderful so we have about 70 grand for
the 19 year old and about 20 so far for
the six-year-olds it's been pretty well
um so my question for you is i've
talked my husband into uh close to it
anyway
of hey let's just pay our house right
um so so number one i think that's the
way to go
but then how quickly do we do that and
then
or do i do i do that and mutual funds
or that's where i'm kind of struggling
um do we just dump
everything into the house or do we look
at maybe mutual funds as well
or not look at that until after the
house is paid
do you mean above your 15 jennifer
exactly yes sorry yes well i would
i mean again the baby steps are there
right so fifteen percent of you come to
retirement you know you said your kids
college is there so i would throw
everything else
at the house uh how much do you guys
make
we make about so after taxes a month is
about 14
grand so we do pretty well um and i
don't want to work forever
i want to retire early my husband thinks
i'm crazy but
i really i just want to get the house
done but so
because i had kind of figured out a plan
i said hey we can pay it in like six or
seven years
doing the math but do i do i not do the
math or just that you know kind of
dump as much as we have left over or
that's where i'm struggling i'm a
finance person for my job and i'm kind
of like i want the calculation
how to do that well what we talk about
is up through baby step three which
you're through that
you have to be intense you have to be
intense you do nothing
until you get those steps done out of
debt and have your emergency fund in
place
and then when you move into baby steps
four five and six those are simultaneous
and you move from intense to intentional
and what that means is you're um you're
gonna say you're gonna set your finance
person so let's just set a formula to
this
uh there's three things we can do with
money we can give it
be generous with it and you should you
can enjoy it
and you should that's lifestyle and
purchases and so forth
and we should invest it and you should
and so
paying off your home here is a type of a
move an investment type move
so the point is if you dump every little
single thing
out of your whole life and you have
absolutely no life until you get the
house paid off
that is not our recommendation okay
that's not intentional that's intense
now if you had a bunch of credit card
debt i would do that i said i set your
hair on fire you get this done right
but this is not here we're just going to
be intentional so we're going to do our
15
of our income into retirement no more
investing other than that
other than if you're going to add do
something to supplement the kids college
and you may need to do a little of that
and then beyond that money that we find
every dollar we consume on a trip
or a car purchase or a
consumption means we don't reduce the
house
and every dollar we put on the house
means we don't enjoy
that money today we're going to enjoy
that money later
okay so you don't want to do all of
either
in other words enjoy it all and put
nothing extra on the house
bad idea but put so much on the house
that the budget is so tight that it's no
fun
bad idea and so i would set myself
budgets for
lifestyle inside of your existing
monthly budget
and then just say any extra we're going
to throw it at the debt and right now
that looks like five thousand dollars a
month that looks like
six thousand dollars a month whatever it
is until we get the house paid off now
when the house is paid off that's baby
step seven then you load you max out all
your mutual fund i mean all your
retirement accounts
and you you know you increase your
outrageous generosity at that point
and you increase your outrageous
enjoyment
of money at that point because then
you've you know that's the touchdown you
now you do the touchdown dance so
rachel's exactly right
uh whatever found money you know if we
want to go back to our old uh
econ class disposable income that we
have
beyond our basic investments beyond our
basic living
and enjoyment of money every dollar we
can find beyond that i'm gonna throw it
at the house because i'm gonna get done
as fast as i can without putting my
family in a strain and i'm gonna say
with the numbers you've got it's
probably about a five-year mark you're
gonna be done
and what happens to the one of the
reasons
that's in the baby steps versus just
living with the mortgage for 30 years
like most people do
is because once you have no payments
then you have suddenly to have so many
options jennifer
you said you want to retire early and
that's not crazy if you got a paid for
house and no bills i mean
yeah sure and by then you will have
substantial investments as well
yes absolutely so it just opens up a
whole other level i mean obviously
getting out of debt
consumer debt does that but
when you don't have a mortgage even not
even a house payment it's on it's like
tenfold it just gives you so many
options and so
i don't think you're crazy for one
retire early you're in front of the
screen yeah get it paid off as fast as
you can
without sacrificing without pension down
on everything to the point nobody can
breathe yes man that's what we
now if you can't breathe in baby steps
one through three you're doing it right
i mean you need to be wild on that one
that that's i mean you need to be in
panic mode you don't have an emergency
fund you got a bunch of car debt
student loan debt uh credit card debt
and that kind of stuff
that's when you're a normal american and
you have a mess and you need to clean up
your normal because normal sucks
but that's not where you are you've
moved from that intense
section of one through three to
intentional
and this is where baby step millionaires
are born they get the home
paid off uh last hour we had a debt-free
call
or a debt free scream here in the st in
the audience and they're 39 years old
with an 800 thousand dollars paid for it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah before they're
40. yes yes before
and they paid off 800 000 house in
austin texas
and we didn't ask them details about
their investments but their investments
are well in excess of 200 000 so they
are not even 40 and they're millionaires
why they've
exactly followed what i just outlined
for the last five minutes with her
this this idea of intensity until you're
debt-free and have the emergency fund
then intentionality 15 of your income
into retirement
kids college is addressed and baby step
six pay off the house with any
disposable extra income we can squeeze
out of our budget and throw at it
without putting the family
in some kind of a ridiculous strain yep
absolutely and you'll do it in five
years you really will and it's enjoyable
that way
yeah and you know it's you just wake up
you go well there it is
i did it there it is i did that's how it
works
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
well if you're in debt uh
it can feel like you're fighting a
losing battle you can feel like you're
stuck
like the freaking bills are winning i've
been there i remember
you may wonder if you're ever going to
get out well it doesn't have to be this
way
when you attack this debt like your life
depends on it
you can take back your paycheck and take
back your life you can start building
the life you want
and we're going to help you get there
we've helped almost 10 million people
get there with financial peace
university it's a proven plan these baby
steps we talk about all the time we walk
you right through it
and we've helped millions of people pay
off their debt and lots of everyday
millionaires lots of baby steps
millionaires out there that we've met
and that's why you get the premium
version of our budgeting tool every
dollar it's in there so you can do all
the planning and the right and
everything
rachel helps teach you how to run the
every dollar
app and it's all only available as a
ramsey plus membership financial peace
university
every dollar many other things as well
all at ramsey plus
to start your free trial at ramsey plus
uh text trial to 33 789
text trial to 33 789
also ramsey plus members get access to
stuff like this uh
money and marriage event which is coming
up one week from friday
it is uh friday the 16th and it's rachel
and dr john deloney rachel cruz and dr
john dolone money and marriage
the second time they've done the event
together they did it at valentine's it
was amazing
and this event has really been a big
hugely popular
if you're not a ramsey plus member uh
it's only 20
right now prices are going to go up this
week
uh one week out they're going to be more
expensive so either get your 20
purchase or get your free trial to
ramsey plus and
while you're in there you can watch the
uh money and marriage event as well
again text
trial 233 789 if you want to just buy
the 20
ticket you can text marriage to 33
789 and get signed up either way
our question today comes from this
wonderful american company blinds.com
they're a 100
satisfaction guarantee place that means
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they're going to remake your
window blinds for free
you have free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best
possible deal and today's question comes
from
matthew in tennessee my fiance and i
will be getting married in november
we're both 20 years old
i make 60 000 as a welder she makes 12
000 as a preschool teacher and is in
college
i have no debts and also a 401k she has
about five thousand dollars in student
loans
and a car loan we have an apartment
together and a joint bank account that i
put money in
for her to handle my bills while i'm out
of town for
work how does the whole process what
does the whole process look like when
combining finances
after getting married um
well matthew sound like you're kind of
already doing it a little bit so
between now and november i know it
sounds like a hassle but honestly i
would still practice
separating those finances until you guys
officially are married in november
stuff happens and you never know
so i would still keep things separate i
would not pay on her debt right now
i would be paying my own bills again
keeping it separate until you guys
get married say i do and then the moment
you guys do that
then what you're doing now which a
little bit of practice which is good is
the
joint checking account so having one
account that you guys are working out of
this is a big hurdle for a lot of
couples it's tough for them to combine
accounts for many different reasons but
that's a tactical step for you guys to
do and then
see this debt that she's bringing in
which is
some student loans and a car loan as
your debt that it's it's our debt
together once we're married
and for you guys to pause that 401k
that you have and take all the extra
money you guys have and
and pay off this debt and get an
emergency fund so that's kind of the
the way to look at it get the plan um
but there
is there is such a push for me when you
get married and only when
that you say okay we have one budget we
have one account we're working out of
and that
unity is created kind of almost this
forced communication in a sense
um after after the after the wedding
yeah
after the wedding when you do one
checking account um
that forces you to to talk about
money and to have a planned budget
because if you don't you're gonna
overdraw the account because she's
writing checks you're writing checks
you're she's using debit card using
debit card
and we don't know what the balance is so
the only way you can run an account
together
is it forces you to communicate about it
it forces you to have a budget and to
stick to it
uh because if you don't you're gonna
screw up your checking account you're
gonna overdraft
and you're gonna be mad at each other
because you can't just run off and do
your
own thing anymore cause you're married
this is how marriage works you do it
together
and here's the beautiful part about the
whole thing when
when you combine your spending
and you agree on your spending jesus
said your treasure is where your heart
is
when you're in agreement about what our
future looks like and that we are moving
in the same direction
you create a level of unity in your
marriage a level of communication you
cannot do with any other subject
money forces you to combine your
value system you have to say
we value saving we value generosity
we value investing uh
we value spending on money on
x or y as a couple
and or she values this and i love her
and so this is something that we put the
category in
for her but and i value her having that
thing
yeah whatever it is art class or what i
don't care what it is okay
but it's not just you know
the mistake that people are making in
our culture today
and it's going to be so detrimental 10
years into your marriage
20 years in your marriage it's going to
be a problem is you
think that you can live this life of
independence
with your roommate and that is not
marriage
and you're going to get into a problem
and you guys are probably going to talk
about that marriage
marriage yes because it's so interesting
out of all i'm
independent then don't get married no
out of all the things
that i talk about specifically on social
media the one thing that people get
so angry at me i mean the con it's the
most hateful comments that i get
is when i say join your bank accounts i
mean you would think
that i like ran over someone's dog and
like laughed in their faces i mean like
you would think i'm the most horrible
person in the world and so
what i'm finding is the more and more i
dig into the subject which again john
and i are unpacking so much of this
because it's not just that it's not i
just won't join my checking account
there's a level of control people have
there's a level of trust that they don't
have with theirs i mean there's
so many of those issues you guys that
it's unfortunate really
they don't want to deal with their crap
and they get mad at the avoidance
and they and but they call it like
feminism or something like that
well you don't want women to have a
voice no we demand they have a voice in
the budget with their husband
rights rights we demand the husband has
a voice in there with his wife
and so i'm telling you too it's in money
fights
and and conflict when it's avoided
sure you're not having it because you're
not talking about it you're living two
separate lives financially
and if and people say well we just fight
all the time so like it's just worth not
like if you're choosing to avoid what's
going on in this situation
what other things are not you're not
you're not pressing into conflict at all
right
in marriage avoidance is not a technique
[Laughter]
less spirit that says buried married
problems have a high rate of
resurrection
they're coming up yeah but it just but
it again it's it's this mirror of like
all this other stuff so it's just funny
i'm like you will share a child like you
will create a human being
and share a child and share decision
making about that
tell me i have to share my money because
i'm independent
but that but it is crap i know but it is
strong out there with people so
that's big that's big so it's fun well
it's misguided
toxic version of ladies having their
voice
yes ladies ladies need to have their
voice yeah yeah there's
there's that side that's what they're
attacking but there's also there's also
another side where he's like i don't
want to deal so they don't
don't [ __ ] at me about that they [ __ ]
you because you're a woman maybe that's
what it is i don't know but it's it's
that side but there's also the guy's
side too
saying stuff like oh i don't want to
deal with it we're so much better
if we're just separate oh i know that
but i'm like dude they're not they're
not they're not hating on you though
i love everyone everyone hates it
i love it i like to be liked i love it
stir up a holy ruckus i like a good holy
ruckus
it's a good thing this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free
stage evan and anna are with us hey guys
how are you
hi dave and rachel hey how's it going
guys welcome so good to have you where
do you guys live
we are from bedford texas basically dfw
okay
so good to have you welcome to nashville
and here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off
just over 62 and a half thousand dollars
all right very good
and how long did this take 14 months wow
your range of income during that time 80
000 to 140.
wow nice jump nice jump in a year
somebody get a job or a raise or what
well i'm based off commission sales so
had a good year
yes i like it what kind of debt was the
63
000 it was a little bit of everything so
student loans was the biggest chunk and
then we had car payments
uh some medical debt and then we also
leased some cell phones
if that was included so just everything
you were kind of normal
all right what do y'all do for a living
i work from home i work for
for a non-profit we specialize in early
childhood education and i
work in accounting okay and then i work
for a tech
company that focuses on the used car and
wholesale business
wow oh yeah well yeah that's a good yes
that's a good place to be right now
thank you man very good so uh how long
you guys have been married
it'll be six years in august august 15th
five years into your marriage four years
into your marriage something flipped and
you said
i don't want to be normal anymore tell
me the story what happened
so we have both known about you and your
plan since about high school i actually
uh my church growing up offered
financial peace so i
went through the class and then you read
the total money makeover
i believe in high school as well so we
both knew about the plan
but we got really serious about it i
started listening to the podcast like
right when we got married
and we would always say like oh one day
we'll do this
and so but it got really real for us
when we had our daughter
and when i when we went from two
full-time incomes down to me working
part-time at home
like we kind of started to feel the
financial stress of that
so that's kind of how old are you gosh
we're
29. yes okay yeah because there's
something about a baby that says
okay you got to grow up now yes
for sure it's like yeah it's like i
remember that i was like
oh crap this just got real oh yeah
especially with commission based sales
oh yeah it's not a game anymore no yeah
it's like people want to eat now
yeah and stuff and stuff yeah and
diapers and stuff yeah
and pediatrician bills and stuff yes
wow for sure you guys are amazing i love
it
what a great why though that's about as
noble a thing
to say all right i'm going to throw my
shoulders back we're going to get our
act together because we got to take care
of this baby yes
when you see your baby yeah it's very
real yeah so did one of you kind of push
it
so you're like okay when did you feel
the urgency more than the other
yes i would say it was me i we started
getting especially after the baby we
started getting like all the medical
bills after that and i was like oh my
gosh and we were both very overwhelmed
and i was like okay we gotta take care
of this so i pulled like our last three
months of bank activity and i was like
had my excel sheet and i'm like we're
spending how much money on like
amazon and eating out and so i just said
to him i was like
those two categories alone will make you
thank you yes absolutely exactly so i
just can't keep up with it
i knew like we could definitely survive
offer the income from switching me
switching to part-time
so i just said not only can we do this
we can attack our debt and let's go
and he was i was all for it it happened
like two months before covet hit as well
which is great
like perfect the lord's timing really
yes with all that because if not
commissions took a pretty big hit uh
let's say at the beginning of covet
until
right most recently so yeah and now
they've come back to like on fire
absolutely yeah yeah like doubled up yes
so
very good well that's so fun you guys
congratulations
to you how's it feel it feels amazing
free so relaxing especially from a
commission
because like since our whole marriage
i've only worked in commission my
entire adult career and so not having to
worry about
what we're gonna make month to month
like if i have a good month great if i
have a bad month it's okay we've got
weird though yeah making more sales it
is it's a hundred this is less stress
you don't you're not focused or
something you know
i always talk i tell ourselves guys all
the time i said we gotta get you making
some money because
a hungry salesperson has a smell you
know
that the customer they they should smell
it on you they're like oh this guy needs
the sale horse and i need this stuff you
know
so yeah absolutely it can it can and
when you relax it's just like i don't
yeah and then you take care of the
customer and voila the sale happens it's
very cool
it's awesome congratulations what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
that is
for me it's been starting and keeping it
top of mind
especially in just in my job in the car
business everybody talks about how much
money they make and
how they spend all of their money and so
when you get the money now i just don't
spend it like i didn't go to lunch for
like
everybody would have gone to lunch today
oh i brought lunch um where'd you go
lunch today oh i brought lunch and they
knew i had i had like a
set you know 20 a week for food or for
going out and so that every
now i have two guys at work doing the
same thing so they're all
you're a trendsetter yeah yes this is a
trendsetter
i love it i love it so what was the
hardest part because i know being a new
parent
i mean you get the stress of that yes i
mean and then you're changing the way
you're doing your money
what what was the hardest part would you
say i think we love eating out
and so that and that's where most of our
money was going we realized that
and so just kind of saying like okay we
gotta take we gotta sacrifice this and
just
yeah yeah keep moving and so we were
eating a lot at home and
that was hard and just we were just the
slow process we're like instant
gratification like okay let's
just go and so it was a little bit of a
slower process and it kind of
it just yeah we like discipline of it we
never bought
big purchases like a like if we needed a
fridge or a couch like we never put on a
credit card or anything like that but we
always like if we wanted something new
it was like oh we've got the extra money
let's just spend it because we already
have it instead of putting it towards
something with a purpose
yeah necessarily we had a fridge that
was hanging on by a thread right before
all this and we're like we're not buying
a new one we're waiting
until we're debt free yeah and yes we
made it oh we have a new fridge
yeah it was a nice thread yes nice
thread was hanging on yes
very good very good and so uh
you you brought the new baby with you
what's what's the name in age
joelle she's two all right sweet
look at her all right so uh
yeah you changed her family tree didn't
you yes congratulations she is we were
practicing the scream
in the car right on the way here we've
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
because that's what
this represents you've changed your
legacy and the copy total money makeover
for you to give one of those guys with a
free lunch are the packed lunches to
spur them on and show them how to win
with this yes from how to do what you
did yeah
so proud of you guys your heroes your
heroes for joel she's precious
very very cool good stuff all right evan
anna and joelle 63
000 paid off in 14 months making 80 to
140.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
this is how it's done
man that is so fun sweet oh my gosh
i just think about everyone listening
that's in their 40s and 50s saying oh
if i was 29. i couldn't
it's amazing it's amazing it frees up so
much
yeah when i first started doing this
somebody would say you know
uh where were you 20 years ago i was
going i was broke
i was deep and dead just like you what
are you talking about now 20 years ago i
was sitting right here so
that's right a little time has passed
but you know where were you 20 years ago
i don't know i was sitting here i don't
know where you are but well what i love
about their story is i'm like
you can decide like that's just proof
that you just wake up you're like
i don't like where we are we're going to
just do something different and it
happens you know i mean
and there wasn't obviously a lot of work
a lot of t'challa yes all of the grit
the grind through those 14 months
but you get to make they could they
could have lived how they've lived
for the first five years of their
marriage forever you know and and just
making the decision to do something
different is powerful
and here's what's interesting i mean
every
debt-free screen i i it's not a hundred
percent but it's
90 something percent during the time
they're getting out of debt their income
increases
he goes from 80 to 140 while she comes
home to part-time
yep yep so i mean there's just
you just say all right i'm gonna change
i'm not gonna do this
and there's a power to that like you
like you just said there's a power to
make i have the freedom and the right
to decide yeah to not live like this
anymore i've had it
and you can change you just decide just
like that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five james is with us in
boise idaho hi james how are you
hi dave and rachel i'm calling on behalf
of my wife
she's fighting metastatic cancer right
now and she said that
your radio program has helped her to get
through all the therapy
by hearing you help our fellow americans
with their issues and she finds it very
motivating
my goodness this this call is about our
younger son he's turning 30
and we need to have a tough conversation
with him we think
we're going to call him ian not his real
name just a little background on him he
was in rotc
then he served seven years in the
military he immediately landed a great
federal job
and he loves it compensates him well
he's got a zero debt emergency fund he's
got
he's putting 45 percent of his income
into the federal
uh savings programs and iras and so
forth
his his wife of six years divorced him
against his wishes
and before that divorce was finalized he
began dating a 26 year old girl
and at the one year point of their
dating he gave her an 11 000
engagement ring paid cash for it uh
we've we've seen some red flags we've
worked better on three different
occasions um he plans to move in with
his fiancee
in a home that is titled in her name and
when she was here recently she
told us that she told us openly that
they're going to use his money
for the expensive improvements on her
home and for an exotic honeymoon
and she on the other hand seems to be
giving up on her career
and on earning money she's got a degree
in education
certified teacher she quit the teaching
job she wants to stay home and play in
the garden and
have him do everything um you know in
the mid-20s
and they both say they do not plan to
have any children
and she'll maybe take an occasional
tutoring job or something
she had plans to get a psychology degree
become a school counselor but since
they're engaged she's dropped those
plans
and uh the the help that we're seeking
from you is uh and my wife again with uh
with a cancer saying that she would
never forgive herself
if she died and had not alerted him to
these red flags or these issues that
we're seeing
our son at 30 is very stubborn always
has been
although he has admitted a couple of
times that uh you know remember this you
were right you know in hindsight i
should have listened to you so
you know we have some hope there and my
wife with the
cancer uh treatment that she's going
through she says she's really highly
motivated to discuss this with him in a
loving
way and in a compassionate way just not
sure how
how to go about that effectively oh
james well
number one i'm so sorry about your wife
that's that's heart-wrenching watching
someone you love
go through cancer it's um devastating to
say the least so i'm i'm
i'm so sorry about that um and then
you're
so the divorce is finalized i'm assuming
now at this point with your son
correct with from his ex-wife yeah so
it's it's done and he's moved on to this
relationship
and you obviously don't care for her
right would you say
besides the money aspect and the
motivation for quitting
teaching and working how is she as a
person like you don't do you question
her character
and who she is i'm not sure how to
answer that i mean she comes from a big
family loving family and has
uh you know good relationships with them
um it's just that it appears to us she's
incredibly selfish and
doesn't doesn't do anything to clean up
after herself expects others to do
things for her and
that to me is kind of a significant
character flaw yeah yeah
yeah i hear that um so for me
as i'm sitting here as a daughter in her
30s with my dad sitting next to me
as we're having um i mean when you're oh
we're going to have family therapy
already no we're not no no but if
if my parents had concern um for
decisions
i was making as an adult i think that we
have enough of a history of a foundation
of a relationship to be open and honest
that
they can we can have a talk about it
right but i think
um there's a level that you're not going
to be able to control him
right you're not going to be able to
make his decisions he's a 30 year old
man
at this point and so i would almost
take it as as almost a friend just to
say hey ian
just a heads up like i'm seeing this and
this and from my experience
and from being married to your mom this
long like this is what we see about
marriage and
and we just see this do you see it at
all and almost making it more of his
idea
and going at it more on a peer-to-peer
conversation versus i'm your dad and mom
and we're going to still parent you as a
30 year old man
does that make sense because i think the
tone at which you have the conversation
is extremely important and so and i and
i think also if a parent and a child
for him a grown adult child and your
parents if you guys
still have a a relationship where you
talk
and there's there's depth there there's
a level that you guys can have these
kind of conversations that should be
okay
but also if there's not a ton of
relationship there the conversation may
not go
very far if you activate his stubborn
bone
this this is over
right right yes he'll blow up he'll blow
up won't he
yes it will i mean he's not a little
wuss he's a he's a military man he's 30
years old he's got a good mind
um and if you and he's got a stubborn
streak and if you activate that
he's going to blow up you know that so
you know where the mind feels
you know where the minefields are and uh
i can tell you how to activate it
use your dad voice use your mom voice
use a guilt trip and
a mom's got cancer and the last thing
she wants you to do is be marrying this
chick
none of that'll work all of that will
activate his stubborn bone
say i'll show you i think i'm just an
old man talking i'm not a psychologist
what do you think
yeah there's a lot of wisdom of what
you're saying i can understand it i can
see it we do have a good relationship
with him that's just that
uh if he hears something that he doesn't
agree with he tends to you know
somehow shut down and then well i've got
a i've got a good relationship with all
three of my grown kids
and the basis on which i could approach
this
is the basis that i have up until now
as adults i have largely respected their
boundaries
and so now i've got to respect their
boundaries again
i think it's one of the most frustrating
for version or phases of parenting
is when you can no longer tell them what
to do
[Laughter]
instead you have to talk them into it or
make it their idea or like you would so
i
what i try to do it helps me not to use
my dad's voice because it's a
it's ineffective now my dad voice just
doesn't work anymore
um it doesn't even work on the grandkids
i tried it there it doesn't work there
either it's a completely i've lost it
it's gone
so papa david's gonna practice i lost my
dad's voice but um but the point
all joking aside uh the way i help it
helps me reframe my mind and i think
your wife is the one that
really because she's so concerned about
this and emotional about it and it's her
daughter-in-law which is a really
touchy process anyway
uh and uh and you've gone through one
bad one right and so now we don't want a
second bad one and all that
yuck is do you i i have to reset my mind
i go okay i am not talking to my
son-in-law
my daughter my daughter-in-law my son
i'm talking to
my friends kids that are 30.
now how would i convince my best friend
who has a 35 year old
that he's off the rails because i love
him and he's my best friend's kid
but i could there's no chance of using a
dad voice there i don't even have one
there
so i've got to say what rachel said i
got to go hey man i'm seeing this i'm
kind of worried about you you know i
love you
and you know i know you've been through
a lot of pain with this last thing
and i just i'm just concerned talk to me
about it
and that's how i would do it if i was my
friend's kid right
and you got you got friends that have
kids your kids age right
yes yeah put one of their faces in your
mind
and it resets how you talk
okay that's how i do it like a great
plan that's how i do it because i don't
have a footing to tell these grown
people what to do
now i actually do because they work here
and i can do it as their ceo
but i can't do that in their personal
lives i can only do it in their
professional lives
right because i tell other people here
what to do because i'm their ceo
and so if you work here that's part of
the program right but uh
but i don't get to do that with grown
people
in that i'm in relationship with and
it's so
dadgum frustrating because the reason
it's frustrating is
these are people you love that are doing
stupid butt stuff
and it's one of the hardest things to
watch people that are grown-ups and
stupid is just not illegal
oh god it drives me nuts and some of you
guys when you call in
not this caller but other callers i'm
trying to talk you off the ledge and
you're just like dude
you just keep doing stupid stuff and i
can't talk it's so frustrating
i can't make you do it with my dad's
voice
and so that that's the only way i know
how to go at this dude
is do it on a relationship persuasion
basis
make sure you don't activate the mom
voice of the dead voice because you're
going to activate his
stubborn bone he's going to blow up and
it'll be over
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host my co-host
today number one best-selling author new
york times best-selling author rachel
cruz
ramsey personality and my daughter will
be here answering your questions at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five luke is
with us in little rock
hey luke how are you hey dave i'm good
thank y'all for having me on
sure man what's up so i made a pretty
boneheaded risky move but i'm coming out
on the good side of it i bought a farm
a couple months ago and i bought it for
undervalue and i just got an offer on it
that's going to leave me
with a minimum 100 000 maybe 130
depending on how much
my deductions go on taxes i'm 25
my wife's in school right now and i make
about 75 000 a year and she's
and we have we owe in the house we own
165 on the house and we own 100 on our
school
so my question is is what do i need to
do with this money
um i don't know i know i know i need to
get out of debt but
should i should i live my life and and
work through the debt or
and just invest this as though i'd never
gotten it um
and then reap the benefits later or what
do i need to do
luke you said how much you're going to
make off this 100 did you say
it at least yeah at least okay
well if i woke up in your shoes um
uh once you get the money from this
after it sells and taxes are paid and
it's all
in the clear uh i would immediately pay
off your student loan that's the only
debt you guys have right is that 100
100 000 in student loans uh we have
about a 5 000 other loan for um for a
medical bill okay perfect
yep i would just knock all those out so
you'll be completely debt free
100 percent after sales form which is
amazing any other cash that you have i
would
open up a small money market accounts or
a money market account um
and put the rest in there because that
will get you close to probably your
baby step three which is three to six
months worth of expenses
so having cash in the bank you have that
already how much do you have
there uh about forty thousand
forty okay well i'd go ahead and just
throw that at the 100k
the student loan debt right now i would
i would clean that out keep a thousand
dollars for your emergency fund
so the goal here though lucas is to get
this debt paid off
as quickly as possible and then on the
other side of it with your numbers you
guys are going to have
a savings of three to six months of
expenses um
and then you guys can move on to
investing but i would use the money not
to invest right away like you said i
know it sounds like a good idea let's
just put it in the market
and forget i ever had it and you wake up
65 you're like oh i'm a millionaire
because of this money because the
the sell of the farm but listen if you
don't clean up what's going on
in the present that's going to sneak up
on you so get that cleared
get some money for your emergency funds
and then
you can look at start investing at that
point so okay great that's that's
what i thought i needed but i just i
just needed to hear it from someone else
yeah let's
the baby steps are the process we've
developed over this 30 years that is the
shortest distance between where you are
in wealth
the shortest distance between two points
right straight line
and so that's what rachel did she just
walked you right up the baby steps and
so we're gonna clear the five thousand
dollars in debt today
write a check when you get off the phone
get rid of that medical debt we're gonna
take
everything but a thousand and throw it
at the uh
at the student loans and then we'll
finish the student loans off with the
sale of the farm
now you've got a couple of issues um
one is the the farm deal even though you
came on the show
knowing that we wouldn't have gone along
with the
crazy idea of going into debt and hoping
you can flip this thing and
make money and yet it worked and so you
have the you you're
the guy that walked up to the slot
machine and dropped two quarters in
and made two hundred dollars right it's
going to be real
hard to not do that again
because you think that's going to happen
again some part of your brain still
thinks that works
and you didn't you didn't use that part
of the brain when you were talking to us
you discounted it
but be careful just say i'm not the guy
at the slot machine
because you're going to go do this crap
again if you're not careful
well the level of anxiety that i felt
over buying and
and realizing i needed to sell is
has kind of pushed me away from that but
there is a there is a small bit of me
there
the great news is it worked the bad news
is
it worked right and it might make you
want to do it again okay so that's the
danger now when did you
when was the closing date on the
purchase of the farm
about three months ago so i know i'm in
long term er i know i'm in short-term
capital gains
which means ordinary income and so if
you clear 100 net
40 of that's going to the government
yeah
so you barely have enough to clear your
debt after taxes
and your emergency fund so that's where
you're going to end up unless you've got
something else going on we haven't
talked about but that's right where you
are man
so you're you're a wise young man to
have recognized that you got out with
your skin
intact uh and i i hope you don't do a
repeat because i'm saying that because
that's the kind of crap
i did i would go well you know maybe i'm
the exception to the rule maybe gravity
doesn't apply to dave you know it turns
out gravity applies to all of us right
so i always think i'm the one that can
get away with it there's a level of
arrogance i mean
pride goes before the fall the bible
says and i man i just i've fallen all
over the place and i'm not saying that's
you i'm just
i'm susceptible to that and so that's
why i always warn everybody else
and i think naturally people just have a
higher risk tolerance than others
you know some people are like i just
want that and then something like i i
it's it's there's something about living
on the edge that
they thrive on i mean honestly though
there's a level of that
24 years old we go on our first cruise
we've never been on a cruise we didn't
know what that
was and your mother is the most risk
averse person on the planet saves every
nickel
and she dropped two dead gum quarters in
a slot machine and hit 200 bucks
oh so this was a true story this is a
true story and you know what that 200
bucks cost us
500 because she put every quarter she
got for the next
week into that dad gum sloppy [ __ ] this
she's as risk averse as you get
but she fell for the you know your brain
goes
i know it's rigged i know that they make
more money on it than they may put out
i know in your brain your intellect says
don't do it
but your emotions going i'm the
exception
and you just keep putting oh god man and
i've done that
so many times and i'm not risk averse
risk doesn't bother me
but even your mom and you know you know
sharon's not sharon's not
she's not a wristband but i'm saying in
general sure a slot machine or
playing some crafts in vegas i mean like
every now and then yeah
i don't know anybody did that i won
though i did yeah
your father's daughter i paid for half
my vacation with my friends
and i even had it in an envelope i
really did you're making my point
for me but what i'm saying is i'm not
talking about that
because that's like just i'm not talking
about that but i'm saying though
people's lifestyle with their money
though there are people i talk to and
they
they get a thrill oh i know out of
losing money
on living on the edge of it i mean they
do because it's a dopamine whatever
yes yes stupid telephones
you just gotta keep the dopamine going
keep the smartphone happy
check 63 000 times a day how many times
you check your email today
how many times have you checked your
email 5 000 pounds
at least while we were on the air i
thought oh my god
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
well if you've been paying any attention
the real estate market you've noticed
it's crazy out there
yeah it's not a amateur hour if you want
to buy a home in this market you need a
pro
in your corner if you're going to sell a
home in this market you could leave a
hundred grand on the table screwing it
up
unless you have the right agent that
knows what they're doing that does a lot
of deals
you need a pro on your side really our
agents that we recommend our endorsed
local providers have years of industry
success
they don't compromise your financial
goals they will not participate in you
doing cray-cray
you're they're going to walk away and
let you do it by yourself they don't
want they don't want their name on that
deal
and so no matter how tough the
competition is you gotta have someone to
guide you through this
weird and wacky time so connect with one
of our endorsed local provider real
estate agents some of the best
in the business go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent and you can find a ramsey trusted
agent
near you ramsay solutions dot com slash
agent danielle
is in tampa florida hi danielle how are
you
hi mr randy thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i'm in a position where
i'm thinking about selling my house my
son's father and i
live together and it's not the best
situation
um your blinds.com advice actually was
pretty spot on
as far as our situation goes um i've
connected with one of your elps and i'm
just really torn because i love my home
and i love my neighborhood but
i just want to be able to pay my debt
off and provide better for my son
okay uh so you own the home with
your boyfriend or no sir
it's just me you own it yeah
okay um when is he leaving
uh that's a great question well i'll
give you the answer
tonight i can hear it no no i can hear
it in your voice
you sound really afraid to me
yeah well i'm trying to talk to you
outside and he's actually standing next
to me because she can't go inside
sir um i have about 16 000 worth
worth of debt um it includes a car a
credit card some medical debt from the
birth of our son
that i get no helpless yeah um my home
your elt said that i could potentially
walk away with about 88 000
yeah so i could reasonably pay all that
off i could
set my son up and myself up in a nice
town home or a reasonable town home in a
nice area
good schools you shot all this out what
is your income
uh i just got a promotion at my job i've
been there about 10 years
um i don't quite know what it works out
to be but it's 21 an hour i believe it's
like 44.
okay how old are you
i'll be 32 this monster how old your
baby
eight months
[Music]
okay um i don't know if you need to sell
your house or not
you may that's possible but that's not
your problem today
is it yeah
okay do you have family in the area okay
i do um my mom passed away about two
years ago unfortunately so
um oh you're do you have daddy
a father and brothers in the area
yes i am my grandma my aunt who would
have room for me and charlie
my son okay um you need to get in the
car
and go to your dad's house when you hang
up the phone
i can't do that i've tried that early
why can't you do that
do i need to call the police for you
no sir we've already gone through that
uh well i'm about to go through it again
where are you danielle are you outside
your house right now
yes i am you are okay do you have car
keys where's charlotte where's your
where's your son
in uh his father's end in front of my
car
all right you need to uh when you hang
up you need to call the police you need
to call your father
and you need to get you and your son
away from the sky do you hear me
do you understand
this is not going to work otherwise
honey this is not a house problem and
it's not a debt problem
you and your son are in danger
do you understand me
hello yes sir i'm sorry
where'd you go sir can you hear me yeah
i can where are you okay
okay i'm sorry did you hear what i said
or were you
distracted yes i did so no i heard you
okay
so are you going to sit there in the
middle of the sewage or are you going to
fix it
i want to fix it that's why i wanted to
sell my home and i just to know no no
honey we don't need to call a realtor we
need to
get the boyfriend out of the house and
that's going to involve the police
and or your father and your brothers
he needs to leave it's your house
and you're afraid you understand that
this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
i'm talking to the same one you know
what i'm trying to just feel like god
yeah i know all right i'll tell you what
we're gonna do
we're gonna put you on hold and kelly is
gonna make sure that law enforcement
gets over there okay
no sir don't you please no baby doll
i'm not gonna be i'm i'm not listening i
love you and that baby
do what just needed to know if i should
say how to not
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's just okay it's
okay honey
you're you're you're in are you thank
you mr redfield sorry i trust you
listen listen easy breathe you're in a
horrible situation
and you have to make the moves to get
away from it
okay and part of part of the type of
situation that you are
in is that his part of his psychological
job is he has convinced you that you're
not able to operate without him
and i'm convinced the only way you're
ever going to be able to operate is
without him
you understand me yes sir okay
you listen you are worth
being okay it's worth being okay for
your kid
it's worth being okay it's your freaking
house
he's trespassing we're gonna remove
the trespasser it has to happen
okay you have to get away from this guy
anyone who calls a national radio show
and is in this kind of distress tells me
that there's serious stuff going on
inside your walls
you understand and then once he's clear
we're going to put you with one of our
counselors free
i'm not going to charge you a dime and
we're going to walk with you and
then we can start making decisions about
your finances
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today do you understand
yes sir today and danielle if you feel
like you need
you and your son to be somewhere safe
then i would get out of the house
as well removing him may not
well no you know but i mean after he's
gone you can make this determination
you may need to go to local law
enforcement but you know get a
restraining order you can do whatever
you need to do at that point but you and
the baby need to get out of there
until he's gone and then you need to get
someone to remove him
and it's that simple so
um that's what you have to do and then
you can begin to have a conversation
uh in some form of sanity because the
situation you are in
right now is insane it's an insane
situation you're not insane
but the situation's crazy girl
thank you sir thank you hey we love you
you hold on a second kelly's gonna pick
up okay
and we're gonna make sure you get taken
care of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show rachel
cruz ramsey personality is
my co-host it just so happens that we
have a
crisis trauma counselor as a ramsey
personality named dr john deloney
uh who just happened to walk by a minute
ago and so uh he was able to get on the
phone with the young lady and
um he's
handled uh people like this before we'll
just leave it at that
and uh so the the calvary's on the way
everybody's okay
are gonna be okay shortly so we're gonna
walk her through it and uh
we just work with a lot of uh extreme
situations around here because money
brings that out and so sometimes we can
sniff things that um
how did you know that well it's just
because i've been doing this for 30
years
and i can smell the
other end of a bad dude a long way away
and uh i've seen it sadly too many times
the
great news is dr john's a whole lot
better at this even than i am or you are
for sure
well but i mean like that's scary he's
he's got it under
on the phone with them and getting
everybody
in the right places which is a part and
so it'll be it's all good for you
listeners thank you
you can pray for the young lady and her
child uh she's gonna need it
she's got a long road from here a lot of
healing and good news though
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jordan and selena are with us celine
arcelina
selena selena r withers welcome good to
have you guys where are you all right
hi dave where do you guys live long
island new york
all right nice yeah i took an rv down
here to
celebrate yes how much debt have you
guys paid off
130 thousand dollars good for you
and uh how long did that take 45 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time 120 to 150
cool beans excellent excellent wow what
kind of debt was the 130
uh dave we were disgustingly normal uh
it was
department stores it was you know credit
cards it was a tax
bill it was um student loan debt it was
cars
a little bit of everything wow all mixed
in together
yes what do you guys do for a living i'm
a teacher and also a
real estate agent and i'm a stay-at-home
mom all right
very good how many kids y'all got we
have two oh sorry
fun fun and the uh uh man how long y'all
been married
today is actually our 10-year wedding
anniversary
right dave yeah that's great a debt-free
scream on the 10-year
and an rv trip to nashville
bring it bring it wow
okay so what happened four years ago
45 months ago because you guys have been
on a pretty long hustle grind here boy
has it been um
you know we were about three days before
our next paycheck
and my wife came home from grocery
shopping and i didn't have the heart to
tell her but she would
you know use the overdraft account that
she didn't know about and as a man i
didn't have the guts to tell her that we
were using overdraft account to get us
to
payday and i just so i make too much
money to be this broke i worked too hard
my whole life to be this broke and
there's got to be a way out of this and
um you know
my friend pedro's here from rochester he
drove all the way down and i called him
and
we got together and he helped me
organize my bills electronically and
help me get current but the only problem
was
i didn't talk to her i didn't go to her
because as the man and as the provider
i felt it was my responsibility to try
to fix this
so buddy of mine at work mentioned your
name his name was greg he mentioned the
total money makeover
i read the book in one day it was a
great plan that i liked because it was
steps one steps two steps three but the
only problem is
i didn't mention it to her so i told i
basically there's a theme here yeah
yeah and uh i forever will regret that
and i hope those that are listening will
understand
that if you are in this marriage you
must work together and stop
trying to take the burden and once i sat
down with her and i said listen i'm
sorry i sold the tv and the treadmill
and this and that and uh we need to
we had a lot of friction in the
beginning yeah i wasn't a fan of yours
in the middle and not even yes you're
coming your tv is gone
yeah oh my gosh and uh this guy lost his
mind it was all because of you and i
blamed you so two minutes ago
where are you going dave ramsey who's
dave yeah what
he would ask me like a question about
something i'd be like why don't go ask
dave
[Applause]
and i uh i deserved it rightfully so
because i think
i just took that burden on and once we
started talking about it
uh we started to really work together um
there was less friction when we talked
about the budget
and um you know she really started to
see we both started to see
you know the small debts going away
quick and then we hit some of the bigger
ones
and we started to really have more money
at the end of the month and
uh you know obviously doing a lot of
side hustles the real estate business
that i operate in and i coach three
sports and she takes on all the
responsibility of staying at home with
the kids
right so we really were dancing and
working as a team and uh we really
started to see the debt
really go uh pretty fast in years you
know two three and
you know pretty not at four but we
almost got there yeah wow not quite to
four but yeah wow
so uh amazing all right all right selena
um
this is a funny story but it also
happens a lot
and i appreciate the way you the the way
you guys are approaching it because it's
very helpful for other people
um so the total money makeover is the
whole thing that's what you all use that
was your map correct
you check the podcast or the other stuff
you go through financial peace
university anyway just
just the book i it's okay i listen to
you every day through the podcast okay
and i
can't help but encourage listeners that
i'm not trying to sell something i'm
just trying to figure out what you did
the podcast
was got me through the daily grind every
day on my way to work yeah every day on
the way home right so celina at what
point in this process did you get past
the he's lost his mind because of this
dave ramsey guy
i'm still not
he better take me to a nice dinner
tonight dead gum righty better
yeah i'm gonna tell you what the most
expensive stinking restaurant in
nashville is
i'm gonna set up the reservation that's
what that's what dave ramsey does
that's it oh my gosh that's so fun
no seriously because you said that you
started dancing together so you got on
the same page at some point
yes yeah we did when was that selena
that was awesome oh
it's it goes back and forth you know
sometimes i'm
good sometimes i'm not but i'm grateful
that
it's gone on this path yeah yeah all
right
wow well it's so good to have you guys
so how does it feel though to
i mean 130 000 is just stuff everywhere
debt
is gone feels amazing um you know we we
feel that we have so much opportunity
now ahead of us
and to ultimately give back you know to
people that need it and to
also do things like this trip where we
can just
get an rv that we never used to camp
anywhere we didn't you know we just
basically used it to drive here but we
had plenty of space and yeah
it's so relieving and um i i thank you
guys so much for all the work that you
do here at ramsay solutions you guys are
true
light for a lot of us out there well
we're honored by that and you guys are
you guys are heroes you absolutely did
what it took to go win i'm so proud of
you
what was the uh what was the hardest
part for y'all
hardest part for for us was the when we
got to the larger debts
you got to the cars you got to the
student loans and you're just grinding
and grinding and i the advice i can give
to people out there is listen to the
dead free screams every day
listen to the stories because you're
going to be one of them one day and just
keep chipping away you know i even have
a little turtle sticker on my
dashboard and on my driver's um right
part of my dashboard where i just kind
of look at it because the tortoise beats
the hair
yeah just have to slowly peck away and
that was hard because
everyone's doing all these different
things and consuming things all around
you and going on trips and going out to
dinners and
we're sitting there you know just
chugging along and but you don't have
130 thousand dollars worth of debt that
they do
right i'm so proud of y'all that's
awesome we got we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's what
you've done is change your legacy bring
the kiddos in tell us their names and
ages we have savannah who's eight
and abigail who is six we call her
cookie
all right bring it cookie all right
sweet girls
yeah beautiful and we got a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give to
someone and pay it forward and get their
journey started because it started the
journey for you guys thank you very much
friend having people around you yeah
sure was huge yeah
father was here and my friend from
rochester came down way to go pedro
good job man all right count it down 130
000 paid off in 45 months make it 120 to
150.
jordan and selena count it down let's
hear a debt-free screen that's ready
three two one
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 1-3 they are
like trees planted along the riverbank
bearing fruit each season their leaves
never
wither and they prosper in all they do
harriet beecher stowe said never give up
for that is just the place and time that
the tide
will turn it's amazing that people get
right
to where they're almost winning and then
they quit
and they didn't realize they were that
close one more step
one more push one last piece of effort
would have got them there andy's in
cincinnati hey andy
welcome to the ramsey show thank you
i've been hearing a lot about title
theft lately
and i'm wondering if i need title
insurance
you don't need title theft insurance but
you do need title insurance there are
two different things
title insurance is ensuring that the
title is clean
and that the seller that sold you the
property had proper title to transfer
to you the trade ensures the chain of
title up to that point
that's done at the purchase of the
property and if you got a mortgage the
mortgage company required you to buy
title insurance for them and you could
get an owner's title policy
simultaneous issue for usually 50 bucks
or so yes you do want that the crap
that's on tv you do not want okay
yeah you do not need to worry about your
fraud your property being fraudulently
stolen
that version of identity theft is almost
uh impossible number one number two it's
so
rare that it really happens it's i i do
not understand how they're
getting away with pushing this like it's
something that happens every day
all right well thanks for taking my call
hey man thank you we appreciate you
joining us okay i haven't seen that what
is
so there's a tv commercials on cable
and there's other things on this thing
uh you know
it's uh in the identity theft space yeah
of course we recommend zander insurance
for identity theft protection
and it would take care of title theft
insurance
as well you wouldn't need it because
this covers you for that so it would be
like for instance uh
if someone wrote a quitclaim deed out on
your home
as and signed it as if you signed it
okay
over to them fraudulently signing the
property over to someone that didn't
that it wasn't signed in other words if
it's not your signature on the document
then the deed is not valid it's fraud
yeah
but then they go and file that deed and
so now it becomes part of record then
you've got to go and
fight the fraud but you always have to
fight the fraud with identity theft
that's part of what identity theft is
but the crook
signs rachel winston cruz right on the
bottom of this deed
does like a quit claim deed as an
example back to the crook
and so like you have quit claimed at
your house to them or your property to
them or your
real estate to them whatever and then
they go and record that quitclaim deed
at the courthouse
but all of that is criminal fraud and
it's very traceable
right because you don't get any benefits
of the property unless we can find you
and if we can find you then you go to
jail so it's not like
we're identity theft on credit cards and
stuff see those guys
they came through well they go and you
know they they take the card and they
get stuff
right right and then they disappear
right but real estate you can't
disappear with it
and so you got to kind of hang around to
get the benefits of it
and so it's very difficult to actually
end up
with it's impossible unless somebody
just is stupid and lets you walk away
with their property
right but i mean they're not gonna walk
away because the crook is
readily accessible and goes to jail and
so it's very
uh it's very rare very unusual but
they're running ads as if it happens all
the
time and you need to get insurance on
the title
title theft on your real estate no you
do not okay no you do not
but you do need identity theft
protection which would encompass that
that is under itself
and that's sander insurance and that's
what we have on you and uh
all of the people that work here and on
me and on
you know we've got all of this stuff and
so that that's uh
because what happens then is let's say
title theft did occur and you had xander
insurance
they assign a counselor to take over the
problem and they go
and prove that this was fraudulently
done and then they get the deed removed
at the courthouse
and they get it all undone like they
clean up your you know like bank of
america opened up a credit card in your
name but it wasn't you
because it was a crook well they go get
that they get with bank of america and
go no
no no no it wasn't them this is theft
it's id
theft and then they do all the dadgum
work because the problem with with
identity theft
is not that you actually lose the money
because you don't it's a fraudulent
transaction you're not liable for the
debt if the debt was opened up in your
name
you're not you know obviously you're not
going to let them just take your
property
right in real estate you're going to
fight that fraud but all the work
but it's all hours and hours and dealing
with
stupid people at bank of america are
stupid people at chase
you know because you got the well they
think they think you didn't want to pay
the bill so now you're claiming identity
theft no
doofus i didn't make the bill and so
then they transfer you to the
identity theft department which is
dumber than the department you were
talking to before
and xander people take care of all that
stupidness for you
and it's just oh god it's a parade of
stupid people it's just a problem
so stupid people parade all right
michael's with us in kansas city hey
michael how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um yeah so i was pretty lucky and i got
a job
at a company that granted me stock
options uh
you know that invested over four years
um
and so i have a second year allotment
that's vested that's worth about 182
000 uh pre-tax and i'm wondering
do i liquidate that and then jump
forward to pay off my mortgage
um or would you uh
reinvest it in like an index fund and
then kind of be
just slowly paying off the mortgage
so this was a an employee benefit you
did not purchase these stock options
they were given to you as compensation
yes wonderful and what is the total
package worth right now that all the
stock options
uh i mean estimated values around 650
000
whoa very nice what's your mortgage
balance
uh 90 000 okay all right
well it's kind of a no-brainer to take
enough out to pay off your mortgage
isn't it
yeah why would you have a mortgage if
you got 650 000 in your bank account
i i mean it's not vested yet and it
obviously does depend upon the stock
price
that doesn't depend on the stock price
i'm cashing that crap out and paying off
ninety thousand dollars how much of it's
vested
uh roughly about a third
so you have so let's just say you have
200 000
piled up in the middle of your kitchen
table
yeah you see the 100 bills looking at
you
you see uncle ben he's winking at you
200 000
is laying there it's kind of a
no-brainer to pay off the mortgage out
of that isn't it
i would think so yeah i think so i've
had so many financial people tell me
that well there's a lot of broke stupid
financial people
listen let me tell you all the data we
have on millionaires
they did two major things one is they
get all their debt cleared off including
their home
and the second thing they did was they
load up their 401ks
and their iras and that's the first one
to five million dollars worth of net
worth
beyond that you can start doing some
other things if you want to
but that's the first one to five million
most people never see this any
inside of that belly to start with so
you get there you're in the top
you're one of those dad gum ugly one
percenters at that point so
go ahead and get there first and then
we'll worry about all this other stuff
i did not meet millionaires who borrowed
on their home to invest in the stock
market and got rich
they they're not there i mean we studied
10 000 of them
we they just don't answer the question
they don't go oh yeah we leveraged our
home all the time and we never paid off
our home because we wanted to keep
investing
they don't say stuff like that but but
people with financial blogs living in
their mother's basement say stuff like
that all the time and oh let's put it in
bitcoin and
all kinds of stupid butt stuff so no
don't do that let's just use some common
sense
lay a solid foundation in your life that
gives you a lot of peace you got 650
000 freaking dollars way to go man
that's awesome i'm so proud of you
it's so incredible yeah so let's pay off
the mortgage immediately
and then from there you're 100 debt free
make sure you have three to six months
of expenses set aside for your
emergencies
and then it's time to be outrageously
generous enjoy some of the money
and have a systematized plan for
investing the rest of the world
i think when when he says yeah i'm
getting all these different opinions
when you run the numbers the investing
option looks appealing right yeah but to
say okay
you get to do that still you could do
all the above yeah because you got it
and when we're done we still have 500
000 dollars
to play with it right that's right it's
right so plus yeah it's in really really
good shape
pretty amazing that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books great job
rachel
thank you very much thanks for hanging
out we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermzyshow.com
you